good evening welcome to the science
industry and Business Library tonight's
program is inside the FDA the business
and politics behind the drugs we take
and the food we eat the author is friend
Hawthorn she's a senior contributing
editor of the institutional investor and
she has covered the healthcare industry
and business for publications such as
Fortune Businessweek and cranes New York
Business tonight she's going to discuss
her book about the Food and Drug
Administration's and how it balances
safety versus the benefit of new drugs
so please join me in welcoming Fran
Hawthorne well thank you all and thank
you jackie for inviting me thank you all
for coming I think when people think
about the FDA
I think they usually have one of two
questions
one question is I hear that there is
some great drug for cancer or AIDS or
multiple sclerosis or whatever that
people are getting in Europe and they're
getting in Brazil and why can't I get it
why is the FDA holding up this drug why
won't it let me have my alternative
medicines that's one question that came
up a lot in the 1980s with AIDS drugs it
comes up a lot with alternative kinds of
treatments
it can come up with any kind of drug the
other question is the one we've been
hearing more in the past year and that
is how did the FDA let Vioxx get on the
market why does the FDA let dangerous
drugs get out there are the drugs in my
medicine cabinet safe now as I said it's
been coming out a lot in the past year
with concerns about Vioxx and celebrex
and Bextra with the teenage use of
antidepressants with a cholesterol drug
Crestor okay oh and this has been more
of a concern this year but these are
really constantly the history of the FDA
it's it's stodgy its bureaucratic it
keeps drugs from the market no it's too
sloppy it's too fast to let dangerous
drugs out it's it's too slow it's too
fast it it stifles industry it gives in
to industry
economists talk about type 1 and type 2
risks a type 1 risk is the sin of
commission the FDA approves a drug
people use it it's dangerous people die
type 2 risk is the sin of omission
the FDA hesitates delays doesn't approve
a drug people don't get that drug and
they die so this has been going on with
the FDA for decades they're criticized
on both sides you know I spent four
hundred pages writing about it how do I
fit it into a brief speech tonight so I
decided the best way to go about this
was to focus on one aspect what is often
the unspoken subtext behind this debate
and that is how much influence does
industry really have on the FDA but
before I can get into juicy part I do
have to explain how the FDA works so you
can understand how industry does or does
not influence the process by law the FDA
must consider two factors in approving a
drug is it safe and doesn't work so in
order to do this there's a whole system
of what's called clinical trials or
tests on human beings
the FDA has set up a whole procedure and
drug companies must follow this they
start out in what's called phase one
where you test a drug on a few dozen
healthy people for maybe a year we test
it to see if it's safe if it seems to
pass that test they go to the next step
Phase two where the drug is tested on a
few hundred people who have the
condition the drug is supposed to treat
and it's tested for maybe two years and
then they start looking at they're still
looking at safety and they're looking at
does it work does it ameliorate the
condition if the drug seems to pass that
test goes to Phase three which is
basically a bigger version of Phase two
several thousand people for three years
same thing doesn't work does it
is it safe if the drug seems to pass all
these tests
then the drug company submits an
application to the FDA and their various
technical terms all simplified and just
called a new drug application if the
drug is very innovative different
controversial the FDA will probably call
in a panel of outside experts called an
advisory committee you may have heard of
this term it came up a lot just a couple
months ago when an advisory committee
met to talk about Vioxx and the similar
drugs these are people who are not on
the staff of the FDA they're practicing
physicians professors experts in the
field and they will give their advice
also if a drug is for a condition that
can be fatal if there are very few other
treatments for this condition the drug
may get to speed through this trial
process
it's called fast-track you can skip part
of the trials do them later okay various
things like that but that's the basic
setup okay so how does a vioxx or what
any other drug get through all these
trials you got to remember first of all
every drug has side effects these are
powerful molecules chemicals or biologic
compounds they're supposed to be
powerful you want them to go in your
body and change something that's gone
completely wrong okay they've got to be
powerful if they're powerful odds are
they will affect more than the thing you
want them to affect they will have side
effects drug trials cannot catch every
side-effect several reasons
think back on those numbers I gave you
the trial is at most five years but it
doesn't go a single person doesn't get
tested for five years and Phase three
one person might get tested for three
years or one year or six months if you
have a drug where the side effects don't
show up for ten years or twenty years no
child is going to catch that all right
if you have a drug that causes a side
effect bad side effect in 1 out of 1000
people most experts say the trials will
not catch that now this gets trickier
because I told you already they're
tested on 5,000 people so
numerically you should 5:5 side effects
right well of course it's never that
clear-cut but here's why 5,000 people
don't walk into a hospital at once to
get tested you've got the phases you've
got no two years here when you're here
the trials take place at hundreds of
sites hospitals universities special
organizations that do it each site will
have 20 or 50 people and they're
different periods of time now right so
let's say out in California and you're
one of phase three there's a drug being
tested and one person has a heart attack
okay the company notes that the person
has a history of cardiovascular problems
though I don't even know if it's related
to the drug okay they record that two
years later in New Hampshire someone
drops out of a drug trial he's he's had
some shortness of breath but he's really
going through anxiety he's going through
a horrible divorce they note that he
drops out they might know why they might
know divorce they might know charges of
breath was it anxiety was it the drug
two completely different cases two
different hospitals or universities are
testing them you might or might not even
record two cases of side effects you
might record one and nobody's trying to
hide anything this is just the way life
is life is messy and even even if you
record two heart attacks you're testing
on a 5,000 people you got two heart
attacks
nobody's gonna pull a drug for that you
know were the two flukes who knows so
the drug will go on the market then it's
taken by millions of people
there were over 22 million prescriptions
written last year in the United States
obviously not for all the same drug but
anyway drugs can be taken by millions of
people then there's two out of five
thousand become hundreds and then it's
dangerous but maybe they don't an
addition there's a couple other factors
to think about um yes drug companies do
hide bad results that does happen does
not happen every day but sure it happens
probably warner-lambert hid
some side effects bad side effects of
its diabetes drug rezulin it's still
under litigation I did some reporting on
it and one of the chapters in my book
maybe Bayer hid some side effects on
Baek all the cholesterol drug both those
drugs have since been pulled from the
market does happen but that's not the
main reason dangerous drugs get on the
market it is rare the other thing you
have to consider remember once again
weighing the risk of the drug the need
for the drug so when the FDA looks at
the side effects it doesn't just say oh
my god you know a heart attack or
whatever acne you know uh it looks at
how serious is the side effect how
widespread is the side effect and how
serious is the side effect when compared
with this condition the drug is treating
think about cancer people go through
chemotherapy for cancer they lose their
hair they get nauseous those side
effects are worth it to save their lives
right most people would think so on the
other hand that was the controversy over
Vioxx it's a drug for arthritis and for
pain and and indeed it can be very
painful I I've heard people stories you
know about how they felt crippled is you
know a captive in their wheelchairs they
couldn't move you know until they took
Vioxx so it's an I don't make light of
the condition but it's not
life-threatening
you take Vioxx you might get a heart
attack that can be life-threatening
for most people that risk is not worth
the benefit of the pain relief from
Vioxx so that's you know part of the
balancing I want to read you a quote
that doctor Janet Woodcock said to me
she is the Acting Deputy Commissioner
for operations one of the
highest-ranking people at the FDA so she
said quote we're making a risk and
benefit calculation a cancer drug could
never be used for hypertension it would
probably be too unsafe unquote in other
words the side effects that you would
allow in a cancer drug you would not
allow in a hypertension drug their
hypertension is just not as serious as
cancer I'll run a couple of their
numbers by you just so you can get a
sense of the balance
in 2001 Merck did a trial of Vioxx when
it was you know all in the market and
everything and in that trial 5 out of
1000 people had some sort of
cardiovascular problem this was
considered serious enough that the fda
demanded stricter warning labels and
Vioxx the trial last September that made
the news in that trial 15 out of 1000
people had cardiovascular problems and
Merck yanked the drug so that's that's
one comparison 5 out of a thousand a
warning 15 out of a thousand off alright
so those are kind of the parameters of
how things work so where does industry
come in industry is very powerful but
you must also keep in mind it is one of
three powerful forces pushing on the FDA
so let's talk about industry first
industry ok wants to make money right
there are private companies that make
drugs they want drugs that sell at least
500 million dollars worth a year to be a
blockbuster to make big money
so again if you do the math if the FDA
takes some extra time asks for more data
pulled off for each month extra that a
drug is not on the market Merrill Lynch
has calculated that the drug companies
lose of 40 1.7 million dollars I don't
want to lose it they want to push it
through so they lobby and they pressure
and there are five basic ways they do
this and I'm going to go through them
kind of an increasing order of potency
and first I do want to make one thing
clear while they're going to the trials
the drug companies constantly talked to
the FDA and this is not considered
unseemly or lobbying or anything they
have to you know because the FDA has to
approve their trial plans and things
change we want to test an X number of
people we're going to do it this long
we're gonna look for this is this okay
with you you know that's fine it's like
if you have an assignment at school
from a teacher you know before you can
do the assignment you have to know and
what are the requirements how long does
the term paper have to be that's fine
after you turn your term paper in you're
not supposed to go back to the teacher
and say what's my grade so that's that's
where the line is drawn once they submit
the drug application all right so the
first thing industry does we're not the
first thing but one of the things the
least important thing industry does it
nags because the FDA you know somebody
from the industry the drug company will
call the reviewer or the supervisor once
a week once a month with some excuse did
you see this article in the Journal of
the American Medical Association yeah of
course they did they read the journals -
okay everyone knows that they're really
calling to say so what's happening with
my drug that has basically no effect
okay another thing they do they complain
to us the public right you hear them
talking all the time you know we spend
800 million dollars a billion dollars we
spend 12 years developing drugs and the
FDA is so slow it's so bureaucratic and
that doesn't have much effect either you
know get to the good stuff now they pay
user fees there's been a lot of talk
about this recently there was a law in
1992 called the Prescription Drug User
Fee Act or nicknamed padieu feh and this
was a bargain okay I mean a deal I don't
mean like a bargain like a good deal
necessarily the FDA was taking a long
time approving drugs everybody concedes
it was taking too long it was taking two
years so the industry said we will pay
fees but in return we want you to use
that money to hire more staff we want
you to hurry up and review drugs faster
we want accountability we want deadlines
this law has been renewed twice since
then
now most people recently have focused on
the money that's a lot of money over
three hundred million dollars last
projected for the next fiscal year it's
about half of the budget for new drugs
in the FDA but I'm telling you the money
is not the bad part everybody thinks
it's been going on for 13 years now the
FDA expects that they know they're gonna
get it they don't think about it also
the money is not contingent the drug
companies pay this money whether their
drug is approved in two months or two
years whether the drug is approved or
rejected it's not a quid pro quo there's
three kinds of fees they pay they pay a
flat fee for existing an annual fee a
fee for each drug they already have on
the market and a fee for each
application so if you don't have a new
application you're still paying the
other fees that's not the problem with
the user fees the problem is the other
half of the bargain the deadlines and at
the beginning it was a good idea like I
said the FDA was taking two years it was
absurd you know people at the FDA admit
this was a problem so they set deadlines
and the deadlines keep getting tighter
with each renewal of the law I'm sorry
I'll try to talk louder I really
apologize up okay yeah I'm so sorry
alright so their deadlines and each time
the law is renewed the deadlines get
shorter right now for those drugs that I
told you that are most important the
innovative ones where there's no other
treatment maybe the deadline is six
months but this doesn't mean that you
turn the application in to the FDA and
the scientists there at the FDA studies
the application for six months mm-hmm
first of all you don't have to know how
big an application is it is huge
it is hundreds of volumes each hundreds
of pages okay
well now it's done electronically but
that's the equivalent the reviewer
there's several reviewers who review
this but then it has to go to at least
two supervisors probably three you have
to review their reviews then it'll
probably go to an advisory committee
because it's innovative and new all that
has to be done in six months and on top
of that the former FDA Commissioner Mark
McClelland last year he was bragging and
saying I'm gonna speed it up even more
I'm gonna make it five months that was
his goal that was back when we all
things were too slow that's the problem
with the law it's not the money it's the
other side of the bargain the pressure
dr. Woodcock the person I just quoted
has called this a sweatshop atmosphere
ok reviewers say they just don't have
enough time
all right now there's only three methods
industry uses I'm not done yet the next
method is the pillow
excuse me political lobbying you've
probably again heard stories about how
politically powerful the pharmaceutical
industry is and this is true in most
years it has a bigger lobbying budget
than any other industry in Washington it
has more lobbyists in Washington than
there are members of Congress so you can
kind of have somebody on each senator
each Congress member and a few to spare
and and we've seen the lobbying the
industry has lobbied Congress to try and
prevent people from Rhian porting
cheaper drugs from Canada and so far
it's succeeded it lobbied against adding
a prescription drug benefit to Medicare
for a long time but that's not what I'm
talking about that's not the FDA that's
what I call the macro lobbying what I'm
talking about is a direct lobbying on
the FDA via the politicians and again
nobody talks about this but it
absolutely happens not every day FDA
people say maybe once every six months
you'll get into a company who will go to
the member of Congress it represents the
city the drug companies headquartered in
plenty of them in New Jersey and they'll
say to their congress member you know
we're big tax payers in your district
and we've got this drug sitting at the
fda and it's just sitting there and it's
a very important drug or they'll go to a
member of Congress who they know has a
family member the disease and I say
we've got this drug that could help your
sister your son whatever and it's just
sitting at the FDA and the member of
Congress or his or her health care staff
person will call the Commissioner of the
FDA and will say hey I hear you've got
this drug what's happening and yes that
has impact Congress is the FDA's boss
Congress controls the budget okay
now we get to the fifth in the most
powerful way industry operates and that
is through you and me the public and in
order to talk about that I'm gonna move
into my next topic and you'll see why
because it's gonna come together
remember I said there were three major
forces that influence the FDA one is
industry the second one is us we the
public come in two forms basically one
form and it relates again to that risk
versus benefit balance okay one form is
people who are dreadfully ill or have a
family member who's dreadfully ill is
dying we want those drugs we also hear
that there's some drug that the FDA is
considering that a drug company is
working on and we want it and we don't
care what the side effects are are we
will take that risk and we will lobby
the FDA and we will work with the drug
companies now this is controversial it's
sort of who is controlling whom here the
patient's often work through advocacy
groups the American Cancer Society the
National Organization for rare disorders
you know many many groups okay these
groups get money from the drug companies
many of them you know who's influencing
whom there is nothing more powerful in
Washington that a real member of the
public as opposed to an industry
lobbyists and then distri knows that you
know you saw that back in the early
1990s when President Clinton had his
health care proposal and the industry
invented you know these supposedly real
people to lobby people pay in the
patient groups say look we'll make a
deal with the devil to get our drugs but
the industry doesn't control us we want
these drugs their money doesn't
influence us I want to read you from my
book what I think is a really trenchant
quote from a person in this condition
Michael Katz is a consultant here in
Manhattan he also has a disease called
multiple myeloma which is a cancer of
the blood and he's an official of one of
these advocacy groups the International
myeloma foundation he has also been a
patient advocate on committees of the
FDA
yeah so here's what he said quote the
notion that a person with an active
disease or an incurable disease
is going to either approve a drug well
he met supported drug approve a drug
that's a bad drug just to help the
company that's making the donation or
block approval of a competing drug
because he doesn't want the company that
funds his foundation to get injured
that's kind of ludicrous unquote and I
think he makes a good point all right if
you hear there's a drug out there and
some other companies making it and their
rival gives your group money you're not
gonna argue against that drug you're
gonna go to that company and ask them to
give you money too it's actually what
you're gonna do on the other hand
interest free users these groups as much
as they can the most famous infamous
example was in September 2002 there was
a lug there is a lung cancer drug called
arrest made by AstraZeneca and it was up
before an advisory committee in
September 2002 now this drug is
controversial it has never been shown to
extend lives any better than
chemotherapy on the other hand in 10% of
patients in the trial it shrank tumors
that's a small percentage for those 10%
it was good it was only tested in two
very small trials one trial did not have
proper controls I didn't get into that
but basically you normally test a drug
against a placebo against a sugar pill a
fake drug so this drug was very
controversial AstraZeneca
had been giving it out to 18,000 people
in what's called a compassionate user
program this is very common in the
industry where when a drug is still
being investigated for a
life-threatening disease the drug
companies will give it away and people
are willing to take the risk
the FDA staff had warned against this
drug went to the Advisory Committee
AstraZeneca brought in a lot of those
18,000 people and they went to the
Advisory Committee and they said please
make this drug legal
well the FDA did approve the drug since
then there have been other studies that
come out nothing that has proved it's
any more beneficial than the original
ones there it may cause intestinal
testicle pneumonia it's very expensive
is the risk worth the benefit but this
is a prime case of where if patients
teamed up with the industry and affected
the FDA I said we the public come in
another form too and those are the
consumer groups that are concerned about
the other side about safety and that
group has been much louder in the past
year probably the most famous
organization is called Public Citizen
but they're not the only people who
speak out on this you'll often find
relatives I was at an advisory committee
meeting about a year ago that was
looking into the issue of teenagers who
use antidepressants and I mean there may
have been lobbying groups there but what
was there was dozens of parents and
grandparents and relatives and friends
each one got up for hours this one on
got up and they said my 14 year old son
took zoloft and he hanged himself my 16
year old daughter took paxil and she
hanged herself over and over believe me
this was powerful and it was painful
okay don't think that doesn't have power
most powerful thing in Washington is a
member of the public or family member to
who is ill or dying whether because they
couldn't get a drug or because they took
a drug both are powerful okay now we get
to the third force that affects the FDA
and that's politics
now there's traditional politics and
there's new politics traditional
politics fits in with that balance again
safety access and I kind of talked about
this already the industry lobbying
Congress the public lobby in Congress
Congress people then calling the FDA
it's all part of it members of Congress
can also bring FDA officials onto
Capitol Hill for hearings and
heathyr no fun to go through if you're
being grilled by member of Congress
there were a couple last fall the house
called the FDA in about anti-depressant
how did you let these drugs on the
market the Senate called the FDA in over
Vioxx okay so that is your traditional
lobbying and as I said Congress is
extraordinarily powerful because it
controls the budget usually it's you
know the members of Congress are being
badgered by the industry in the public
just like the FDA so they'll press the
FDA on the side of safety or the side of
access but a new force has entered
politics now that isn't arguing and
either of those traditional grounds
puppet first began about 10 years ago
but it's particularly happening in the
last couple years and it's going to
become more of a force this is a force
that in the last election was called
moral values this force mostly lobbies
and drugs dealing with reproduction
abortion pregnancy birth control but not
entirely I want to tell you one story
where it came out this was last year
there was a drug called Plan B he might
have heard about this this is called an
emergency contraceptive or a
morning-after pill the idea being that
you know if a woman has sexual
intercourse doesn't use birth control
she takes this pill within 72 hours she
won't get pregnant
okay this pill has been sold in the
United States since 1999 approved by the
FDA safe effective by prescription the
manufacturer came to the FDA about a
year and a half ago wanted permission to
sell it without a prescription what's
called over-the-counter for the obvious
reason that if something is an emergency
pill needs to be take within 72 hours
the patient may not have time to make a
doctor's appointment see the doctor get
a prescription and the FDA considered it
went to an advisory committee there are
set standards for the FDA to review the
idea of an over-the-counter drug again
based on safety and efficacy these are
questions of can the drug be used safely
and effectively without a doctor's
supervision can a normal average patient
understand the instructions
is it something easy to take like a pill
you swallow or is it something you
inject you ok standard question
scientific questions but the people
lobbying against this pill did not Lobby
on those traditional basis their
argument was this pill will encourage
teenagers to have sex and this is a bad
thing because the teenagers don't have
to go to mom and dad don't have to go to
the doctor could just walk in the
drugstore and this is a very serious
debate in our society and I don't mean
to belittle it are we as a society have
not decided really this issue if you
make birth control more available does
this encourage teenage sex or in fact
teenagers are gonna do it anyway so it
prevents unwanted pregnancy so now I'm
going to be but it is not a debate about
safety of the drug and it's not a debate
about whether the drug works it's a
debate about social values ethics
sometimes religion and what was
extraordinary last year about this drug
several things the Advisory Committee
voted 25 to 3 to allow the drug to go
over the counter but the three people
who voted against it voted on the basis
of those social issues after the
committee voted the FDA was flooded with
letters mostly against the drug mostly
for those social value reasons 49
Republican members of Congress wrote to
the White House asking that the drug be
rejected this is unheard of since when
does the White House make a scientific
decision as to whether to approve a drug
or not was pure politics but the new
kind of politics I mean there are many
more ramifications according to those
padieu for deadlines the FDA was
supposed to decide in winter it got an
extension which you can do you could
extend the deadline until after the
commissioner had been approved by the
Senate for a new job then it rejected
the drug it claimed it rejected the drug
for scientific reasons that there was
not enough data for young women under
age 16 nobody really believes that but
be that as it may the manufacturer came
back last fall and said okay tell you
what we will sell it over-the-counter
only
people 16 and over you're under 16 you
need a prescription okay the FDA under
the Paducah deadlines was supposed to
make the decision by the end of January
it did not once again its had an
extension and funny thing once again the
Commissioner is up for a Senate vote the
old commissioner had been approved for a
new job he went off to head Medicare and
Medicaid person was named acting
commissioner he has now been nominated
to be permanent commissioner at his
hearing in the Senate the Senate Health
Committee he was asked what's happening
with Plan B when are you going to decide
and he said Oh that'll be after you vote
on my nomination pure politics not an
issue of safety it's not an issue of
whether the drug works it's an issue of
do we as a society want teenagers you
know to have this access will this anger
the base of the Republican Party pure
politics and this is not the end these
issues are gonna come more to the fore
partly because it's a growing movement
in our society and also because science
is just getting more and more
sophisticated we can do things with you
know genes that we couldn't do we can do
things with you know fertilization that
we couldn't do before there are two
cases that are going to come to the FDA
next year or I predict you will see huge
fights on these social value issues
assuming of course that the companies
proceed as planned with their trials
next year a company in California plans
to come to the FDA for approval of
clinical trials of a treatment using
human embryonic stem cells this will be
the first time the FDA has ever faced
this issue we know that that is a major
controversy in the realm of social
values ethical values secondly Merck
plans to come to the FDA for a vaccine
for human papilloma virus now human
papilloma virus is the leading cause of
cervical cancer this is a horribly
serious disease human papilloma virus is
spread mainly through sexual contact
Merck says it wants to market this drug
to women and girls between the ages of 9
and 24
so we will have a drug coming to the FDA
for approval for disease spread by
sexual contact to be marketed to nine
year olds I don't know why Marcus doing
that but I somehow think that we're
gonna see some protests and it can't be
on the issue of safety and efficacy
because I can't I mean you can do
anything but the trials so far have been
extraordinary the drug has proven to be
75% more effective than placebo I mean
it looks extraordinarily safe and
effective alright so you have these
three forces right who wins
industry public or politics I wish I
wish I could be simplistic and say Big
Bad industry the FDA just caves in you
know that's what a lot of people think
but it is not that simple
in recent years yes industry has been
very powerful for several reasons one
reason is until Vioxx we hadn't really
had a major recall since 2001 since
baked all the cholesterol drug so people
were starting to feel it safety wasn't
such a big problem it kind of shrank
down in that balance instead the other
side became more powerful we want access
to drugs on top of which drug companies
have been having trouble coming up with
new drugs there have been fewer new drug
applications at the FDA so again there
is this demand this need we need these
drugs we don't have enough so that side
was stronger on top of which the
Republicans have been in control in
Washington and they tend to be more
friendly to industry but in the past
year it's been that other side that's
been much more powerful the safety side
because of the things we talked about a
few minutes ago the dangers of teenagers
using antidepressants and seems that
antidepressants tend to increase
suicidal tendencies the withdrawal of
Vioxx the dangers of the similar drugs
celebrex and extra other drugs that have
been warned about Crestor the withdrawal
of a multiple sclerosis drug recently
for all these reasons the citizens
groups concerned about safety have
really been having much more clout
recently and and industries kind of
shrinking bath
it changes its cycles I mean I I
actually brought a whole bunch of
newspaper clippings just to show you
some of the headlines from a couple
years ago but I'm just gonna give you
two examples
is there anyone from Business Week here
I don't even sell to you personally
alright cuz he's both heard from
Business Week I thought it was good to
have two from the same place this is
from March 11th 2002 new drugs why so
many delays blame overeager CEOs and an
overly cautious FDA and it goes on to
say one of the reasons you know the FDA
is taking too long to approve new drugs
there are so many delays and one reason
an understaffed and leaderless FDA that
may also be over cautious okay two and a
half years later Business Week December
13th 2004 I used to work there I could
make fun of them this it really it's not
just Business Week it's everybody okay
how to prevent another Vioxx and it says
mercs original Vioxx trial should have
been longer larger and more
representative of the general population
in other words oh they should have taken
longer there should have been more
delays okay which year do you want it
comes and goes
economists I'm sorry academics have
tried to measure this as well I think
most the economists economists academics
um you know they love to write put
numbers on everything you know they they
tried to correlate drug approvals with
drug company size lobbying number of
applications number of drugs compared
with speed of drug approvals they have
not been able to find this kind of
numerical correlation the only
correlations that the studies have found
speed of drug approvals seems to
correlate with two things the power of
the public lobbying groups certain
patient groups seem to have more clout
arthritis has more sex appeal than
asthma more influence in Washington and
secondly the number of times the disease
is mentioned in the Washington Post
because that's the hometown newspaper
you don't know visual aid here think
about that game rock-paper-scissors if
you know that game that's the way it is
politicians are the rock consumers are
paper industry scissors
sometimes the public smothers the
politicians with their complaints if the
safety complaints are high enough the
politicians crush the industry the
industry's lobbying is powerful it's got
money it cuts the public to shreds
anybody can be on top so where does that
leave us where are we now right now we
are as I said an interesting new place
the FDA is used to balancing the safety
versus access industry consumers
politicians but we've got this new force
now that the FDA has not yet learned to
deal with and how that will affect the
balance of the other two does remain to
be seen
so with that indecision I'm sorry good
end but thank you very much and I will
try to answer any questions that I
didn't think of an oh I I have to put my
pitch in because Jackie you failed me oh
it's okay if you are interested
wonderful folks from Barnes & Noble are
outside they have some books I'd be
delighted to sign them if you want okay
thank you very much I think that lady
anyone anyone who wants to ask questions
yeah please use that mic and and you'll
be famous so where does a natural
alternative fitting in with all this
novel inand FDA and federal government
and all of that where does the natural
vitamins fit in okay good
the FDA has almost no power over
anything that is not a
or over-the-counter drug that's because
of you the public actually in the 1990s
there was uh the FDA did have the power
to regulate vitamins herbal supplements
alternative drugs and there was a huge
outcry from the public manipulated by
the companies that make these products
and there was a scare tactic and people
thought were led to think that the FDA
was going to outlaw vitamins or require
dozens of years of tests and make them
expensive they were such a huge outcry
you the public the second force
influenced that third force politics and
Congress passed a law explicitly taking
away from the FDA the power to regulate
these with one caveat if the FDA can
prove that they are dangerous then it
can outlaw them so in other words these
products have to be in the market and
kill a lot of people and then they can
be outlawed and that's what happened
with ephedra last year you know a
baseball player died a famous person
then the pressure was on yeah I suppose
if anybody wants to like line up behind
the mic or something that might make it
faster you see I always make the
argument that everybody's biochemistry
is a little different so what may be a
one the drug for me may be a disaster
for you we hear about a few teens who
have hanged themselves or shot up their
classmates their teachers and then
committed suicide but what about all the
teens who have benefited from these and
like the president died psychotic
medication so that goes for any kind of
medication yes and the same thing with
vitamin arrabal mineral supplements but
they work for me may be terrible to you
there has to be more chemistry blood
tests urine tests even spinal taps no
you're right and that's again part of
the whole balance right you know with
the antidepressants should they be
pulled off the market they seem to make
some teenagers suicidal but other
teenagers and their doctors say we
desperately need them because there are
no drugs specifically for teenagers you
know what no antidepressants um you know
the same thing
there's an issue that's sometimes raised
about meat
drugs you know why do we need another
cholesterol drug why do we need another
arthritis drug why the drug companies
wasting their money why does the FDA
approve them partly for the reason you
just said every person is different I
mean I know people who said they can't
take celebrex they have side effects
from it and they loved by ogz okay you
know what we're all different and that's
why well that's actually not why the FDA
approves these drugs the FDA approves
drugs because it has no legal authority
to not approve a drug just because there
are five arthritis drugs there's nothing
in the law that says you can't have a
six but that's partly why they're made
could you go to the microphone I'm sorry
the TV requests they rule everything my
sister is allergic to a lot of drugs and
I'm sure other people are also what do
they do in cases like that well I mean
obviously she goes to a doctor and
that's again we have a light
life-threatening situation they've got
to take a drug and they can't I mean I
don't know what happens with some of
these people yeah I mean if they're
allergic to Turkey see if they're
allergic to everything
that's where you start getting into
medical practice doctors may try
experimenting with what's called
off-label use this is also controversial
get into in my book too but a drug
that's been approved for one condition
sometimes starts getting used for
another condition and sometimes it works
wonderfully sometimes it's dangerous you
know because it hasn't been tested for
that condition maybe they would have to
help themselves nutritionally you know
or through alternative methods to do
absolutely that's another possibility
change your lifestyle you try
alternative you know Eastern medicines
and yoga I mean right there are many
many alternatives
I mean if certain people might have to
take them but they had such side effects
they refrain from even going near them
yeah yeah I mean so I mean what are they
doing about that I mean the side effects
could be worse than the the cure or the
treatment you know in some cases so I
don't know what they're doing about
though whether the future holds any
promise for that again there are several
possibilities sometimes you know then
you end up taking seven drugs instead of
one you take drug a it has
so then you take drug B to ease the
side-effects of a menu okay but if you
could limit it that's what they and
that's what the doctors you know can
help you with away from that guy's
taking vitamin C right yeah the drug
companies right they're constantly mean
that's why these me two drugs get
created they're trying to find a drug
that cures the condition without the
side effects that's how Vioxx began and
celebrex trying to find drugs for pain
that didn't cause the stomach problems
that the traditional drugs caused real
trouble we also know if there's any way
of doing that I mean as I said earlier
you know the trials can only discover so
much um
so unfortunately yeah we become guinea
pigs do you think that these people that
go on these drugs that aren't fully you
know good for them or whatever that they
should probably have to monitor
themselves more with a doctor well you
meet people who aren't drugs before
they've been approved that's with the
compassionate use is that what you're
talking about in any case maybe they
just have to be monitored they probably
just have to be monitored more yeah I
mean this who avoids problems or you
know maybe these people that died from
some of these things weren't being
monitored by a doctor or didn't pay
attention to symptoms or something I
don't know yeah there's a lot of
possibilities you know when the diabetes
drug rezulin was out and they started
noticing dangerous side effects liver
side effects so the FDA kept insisting
on stronger warnings I had four or five
warnings before I was finally pulled and
the doctors were supposed to monitor
their patients liver condition well not
every doctor did they didn't monitor
they didn't read the warnings okay it's
more the doctors fault really than the
patient's fault and things like that
so yeah you can monitor you could read
warnings to some degree as I said we're
guinea pigs but one of the controversies
in the past year is that the FDA is not
doing a good enough job after drugs were
approved to keep track of the side
effects doctors do not legally have to
report side effects it's voluntary
there's a website that the FDA has
midwatch where you can report them well
Congress us the public yeah yeah and
I've FTAs part of the Department of
Health and Human Services so they report
to the Secretary of HHS too
gosh I signs uh in my opinion I feel if
the federal government the FDA Congress
at all would have the most important
priority of the public saving lives and
the bottom line with them is money
I think it's money if we the public use
certain alternatives and find that they
are helpful and help your conditions
certain issues if we have certain issues
and it's being healed or you know
prevent it then F dinner for the drug
industry lose money so I think the
bottom line is money and if we the
public really lobby towards that point
and you know but the FDA they are point
is trying to save money resident to save
lives I think that's the priority to
save lives and prevent disease rather
than once you get a disease and only
only only thing that does is pacify the
pain it really doesn't get to the
problem so I think the bottom line is
money and if we could get the priority
of trying to prevent disease rather than
wait did you get a disease and get a
drug too to help a disease um you know
but the pain that's my opinion
yeah well I think I mean I think I agree
with you and most people agree that
preventionists yeah a lot better than
trying to cure it afterwards I don't
think I don't know if you were saying
the FDA's bottom line is money but I
don't think that's true it's the drug
industry's the drug again there is so
much advertisement on television and in
different media about medications now I
wonder who is responsible to monitor
these at
because I think some of them are very
misleading and if we you know if nobody
controls them and says well that enough
is enough already
so I don't know who can be responsible
for that yeah I mean there just wasn't
time to talk about everything in my book
and everything in the FDA but yes drug
ads I I agree the FDA is responsible
the FDA made them legal the FDA monitors
them and I do think the FDA has fallen
down on the job there you know I I I
will grant that back in 1997 when the
FDA set the rules allowing drug ads on
TV it really didn't have a choice they
had been illegal essentially the rules
were so strict it made it virtually
impossible to advertise on TV and
society was changing you know it used to
be doctors couldn't advertise lawyers
couldn't advertise that changed and it
opened up and the FDA couldn't really
stop the ads but they could have then
and they still could now require that
these ads be what the drug companies
claim they are which is educational
scientific you know um recite you know
the side effects compare them to other
treatments alright and don't fill them
with you know gauzy pictures you know on
sex and you know couples cuddling and
dogs and running to a field and and so
they look like you know tooth paste
dance and or worse yeah I
that's the FDA's responsibility and they
have really I think slipped on that last
year they did a big review of these ads
everybody waited for them to really
crack down and they did nothing
virtually nothing okay you're not gonna
let me go away yet quick question what
about these ads that you hear that are
like I don't really know the name of it
the drug like try benadryl that it's
it's good for you ask your doctor about
it but then you're stuck you're like
well what's that about like you don't
even know what it was and it's like
you're not going to forget the name and
you're not going to ask your doctor
why what's that about I think I have to
do my next speech about ads because
every time I speak people bring up
virtually the same question the FDA and
the drug industry are really not doing
their job either um there are three
types of ads allowed on TV under the FDA
laws if you are going to name the drug
and say what it does then you must say
the side effects that you can't hit like
this you must say them in the same tone
as the rest of the ad and you thought I
was making a mistake there and you must
say things like ask your doctor you must
have an 800 number you must have a
website when you go home and watch TV
now then you'll start noticing those
okay there are two other types of ads
though kind of ad called a reminder ad
and that's sort of what you were saying
viagra used to use this when there were
no competitors viagra
ask your doctor you don't have to say
what it's for everybody knows what it's
for then you don't have to say the side
effects the other kind of ad is called a
help-wanted ad this one does not say the
name of the drug and does not say the
side effects it only says the condition
right are you allergic
ask your doctor okay yeah yeah that
works again when there's sort of only
one famous drug for that condition most
ads are of the first type but that's why
you'll have something now bed as well is
a different case because it's actually
over-the-counter but that's the idea
you're getting out yeah and and yeah
clearly as marketers the drug companies
are really blowing it if people think
they're stupid and don't understand what
they're advertising you know on the
other hand I just think the effective
ads are too effective and they create
demand for unnecessary drugs this isn't
really my question but having worked in
television in the past I'm now retired I
find it amusing that my doctor finds it
amusing that I'm not asking him
questions about the latest drug AG
although they are swamped by the
and this is not funny my question is
that you mentioned in the big in the
beginning two items and the first one
was why can't I get my drugs as they do
in Europe and Brazil and so on and so
what's holding it up does your book get
into the study of how other countries
other medical care systems handle this
matter as we of course do not have a
universal healthcare system as they do
in some of these other countries
parenthetically as different as they all
are they all think we're nuts because we
don't have some kind of universal health
care system does this figure into how
they look at the drugs and as your study
cover how these other countries handle
that in relation to their medical care
system no I'm sorry I had enough trouble
fitting the FDA into one book it's so
huge I I'm afraid I didn't go into other
countries you know now I feel bad do you
own a publishing company yeah they think
about that one thank you I was just
interested to see like how did you get
into this area I work as a listicle
counselor and I would just be very
interested in like how did you decide to
write this book and research this
because it's it's great I'm really glad
to don't you have done that so yeah well
thank you first of all um well it
brought together two areas that I'm
really interested in and done a lot of
work in which is health care in politics
is I have done a lot of writing on
health care I did a book two years ago
called The Merck drug or not which is
about the drug company Merck and the
pharmaceutical industry and I've just
done a lot of writing and newspapers and
magazines some of the ones Jackie
mentioned looking at health from a lot
of viewpoints as a health insurance
system you know as a employee benefit
from the consumer point of view the
drugs on the market
from the industry point of view the drug
companies as well I've also covered
politics and I have to say that's kind
of my first love as a reporters it's
covering politics so I mean this was a
chance to put them both together the FDA
is huge it oversees over one quarter of
the economy which is another reason I
couldn't possibly get into another topic
in one book this anyway that just was a
great opportunity to put all these
interests together and I didn't know I
have to say I knew it was important I
knew it was topical I had no idea how
the news would explode in this past year
so I kind of was lucky on that score
okay please sorry I came late but I was
warning about patent patent law and
that's effects generics and the price of
drugs and the drug companies that are
gonna lose a big drug to patent say ah
data that we're gonna lose millions and
billions of zillions of sales and could
we extend it from 17 to 21 could we be
like another country that may have
longer yeah now that's also a very
important issue that I get into in the
book now patents are issued by the
Patent Office but the FDA plays a role
because it sort of has to certify that
this is a unique process you know
biologically medically um and that's
part of why the industry is so frantic
to get drugs approved and out on the
market fast because they have that
patent clock ticking they have 20 years
in the date of application doesn't mean
from the date of approval years between
application and approval once the patent
expires then generics can come on the
market much much cheaper they lose their
you know cash cow the FDA also comes in
because of what you're getting at patent
extensions the drug companies will play
all kinds of games and and some of the
people some of the drug companies
themselves are angry at their fellow
drug companies for doing this they think
it's it's wrong you know they will have
you ever heard of a drug called Clara
Nix
yeah okay Claire UNIX all Claire UNIX is
simply you've heard of claritin okay
same manufacturer almost the same word
right I think I've got this right
Claro necks is simply what claritin
becomes after you swallow it
okay clarity was a blockbuster huge
moneymaker but it was about to lose its
patent protection so the manufacturer
then took that metabolite it's called
but claritin turns into in your stomach
patented it it had never been patented
made a new drug Clara Nix and now
advertises Clara Nix like crazy of
course and you never see ads for clip
well you just see Eretz for claritin
over the counter but same thing give her
her drug called nexium never heard of a
drug called prilosec prilosec was the
best-selling drug on the earth at one
point little purple pill for heartburn
it was about to lose its patent
protection the manufacturer spent years
researching this took it and changed one
little aspect of it got a new patent
brand new drug 20 years but nexium you
no longer see ads for prilosec and and
nexium is also a purple pill okay and
this is this is legal
then there are other ways they try to
extend patents more like I think more
legitimately if you test a drug on
children you can get extra six months of
patent protection this is to try and
encourage exactly try to prevent exactly
the problem we saw with the
antidepressants and the teenagers let's
test these drugs on kids and find out if
they work and find out if they need to
be changed you know and that if oh if a
drug maker challenges a generic company
it automatically gets an extension just
for challenging even if the challenge is
thrown out later there are lots of games
they play the FDA claims its hands are
tied by law you know it's got it we
don't it's a new molecule that are
stupid they got to approve it you know
they got to you know give the extension
or whatever
well okay I guess I guess I'd answer all
your questions oh thank you all again
very very much